thanked 5s okay from what I recall and
this is going back a couple months I
would think pot sir knows how to play
good and fast so I need to be equal or
better in both of those categories let's
see let us see Roy Lopez Petrov I did
that twice the Petrov takes takes it was
interesting I don't want to enter the
Berlin territory no Berlin walls I don't
want to be dealing with that Bishop c5
would be getting into the game that I
had played against windmill earlier in
the stream where I think it was close to
equal there was that later f6 move if
you were here for that excuse me if
you're here for that earlier game you'll
know what I'm referring to
maybe if you recall that game but there
was a had an f6 move but up until then
it was really really tight
let's do h6 and I don't know if I want
to run with rook e1 Knight d2 to f1 I do
want to preserve my light square bishop
and let's get more development in my
knight would like to get to where let's
I'm going to actually run forward with
this so I don't quite know how it's
gonna pan out my opponent is preparing
to deal with the knight that lands maybe
I'm this square tucking the bishop back
looking for g6 I should maybe be
considering eight three and then maybe
an expansion here there is maybe a down
side with an early d4 move namely after
takes takes the knight can be making use
of b4 with tempo that could be a bit
disruptive so a3 is not necessarily to
expand with b4 in as much as to just
prevent the knight from making use of
the be for square after I have pressed
forward in the center again dd4 takes my
pawn takes away and then this square
would be made available so let's do that
now I am looking at this a bit more
closely my opponent just say you know
what d5 let's go
that's what they might say in response
to that I don't know what I should be
doing I think I want to maybe get my
knight to g3 or not okay let's go let's
open it up right now I have enough
coverage for this pawn and pour in
detail my bishop and rook are here to
watch over it this rook is in a good
spot my opponent is coordinating their
pieces correctly and with this tension
in the center this is where there is
there should be a lot of time devoted
you know okay yes this is a blitz game
but just assuming that we had a lot more
time these are critical positions where
there is pond tension and there could be
the closing up closing of the position
the opening up of the position in a
couple different ways although both
recaptures would probably translate into
this same type of formation it's likely
the case that whether I go like this or
this the deep pond will recapture and
it's the same story so I wonder if just
push is the right way to go about things
and then the attention turns maybe
towards the Kings side or actually no
not just the Kings side both wings
because the center's locked so a play
would ensue on the wings so I'm
wondering about d5 here d5 hmm or you
know kd5 bishop here and then Queen to
d2 could I get the dark square bishop
Soph the board or would that even be a
good thing let's do this I think my
opponent was looking to chop a few times
and then get the bishop at the end of
the variation something along those
lines so let's see where the bishop
wants to reside they're going there and
to that I say all right to that I say
all right should i do Knight g3 no I'm
gonna do b4 to prevent this Knight from
making use of this square and now I
think I want to do what what do I want
to do next
do I want to prevent the knight from
playing here
and getting to this square that could be
a bit annoying I'm gonna do that and if
the night plays here I might be playing
Bishop here next okay now that's not
needed I'm going to keep pressure on
this point so if this Knight
everything's about moving I could chop
right here immediately and then we have
another structural change my opponent
would be having a three to two majority
and I would have a connected past pawn
in the center I would have a two-to-one
majority so I have a time edge here and
what else a time edge and what else
mm-hmm okay that is an interesting one
right there how about I force something
here with this move I'm saying you know
what declare your intention show me your
hand soon I want you to capture me and
if the see file opens up I could be
assured of let's say well I don't know
about shirt but I may be getting ready
to pinpoint the Queen so now that has
locked up I think my bishop is good here
so I'm gonna do that and now that now
this is closed so immediately my
attention is turning over on the Kings
side over on the Kings side is where I'm
heading here and I think that Queen here
is a good start
Knight to h2 is probably going to be a
move Bishop to h6 I want to be cautious
okay the Knights getting ready to go
back to G let me play here
it's Knights
I wasn't doing anything great was it and
you may could get rid of the light
square bishop so I don't know if I want
I don't know what to do here
I'm not quite sure what to do huh this
guy's stupid right here on g3 stupid
night
stupid stupid night what could I do
better with that night where could I get
him where would he like to be where's
the dream square for the night and once
I've identified that how can I get there
I'm not quite sure my opponent doesn't
have any weaknesses just yet that's uh
it's part of my problem okay this Bishop
could use some work did I really want to
stare at this pond for the rest of the
game no didn't want to do that so let's
get my bishop over here maybe there
could be some exchanges on g4 maybe I
could be taking in this direction and
then getting my Jeep on up my king up
and my rook over here on the H file see
with all these files closed it's like
what did these rooks do how can we get
the rooks doing something I'm just gonna
move quick and get a bishop move in
there and force my opponent to get back
to thinking while I'm trying to use my
opponents time then if Queen here it's
losing move Bishop g5 the Queen's dead
less than a minute for my opponent they
are usually the one who is ahead on time
here so see how they respond to that
pawn push again they don't have any
weaknesses okay so I got something out
of that maybe and now can I get to this
square I might want to get to that
square okay I have no I don't have
enough coverage let's come back here
come back here and now we're gonna have
some exchanges or are we I'm in trouble
my bishops dead my bishop is dead I
miscalculated I miscalculated there
okay I got to do this and now I'm look
at my LightSquared Bishop what an idiot
what an idiot
another structural change this game
isn't gonna finish is it okay good no I
that was my good Bishop what am i doing
oh boy let's go here
run King I'm just gonna give that up I'm
just gonna give that guy up there we go
I wonder if this could be broken down
wonder if that could be broken down my
opponent does not have enough time
there's no way I'm just gonna sack this
open it up open it up that's not a good
sack by the way they dropped the queen
drop the rook their time pressure
I had nothing more than a draw after
that yeah nothing more than a draw right
there
good game very solid right here towards
the end again I didn't I was probing for
weaknesses here but there just were
there weren't any my opponent just made
a single pawn move I can't rely upon any
square really here as a whole and ya
know good defense by my opponent I don't
know about the decisions to really close
things up like this right here I don't
know about yeah this stuff right here
with closing up the position on my
opponent's end close close the attention
shifts over here I think my opponent
does have a nice defensive resource I
like the king move urilla allowing for
this night to just come back and watch
over this h6 square
it was nice and then the night coming
back there's somehow there's always some
lateral defense that black could be
having very good defense very very good
and in fact f4 got played and who knows
maybe I'm not even the better side here
actually right because this pond push
and then maybe my pieces are getting
pushed around very nice game I think it
was a very tight the whole way through a
lot of points along the way where there
could have been the position could have
opened up it could have been closed but
entered a closed position on Queen side
and there wasn't really much stuff going
on on the Kings side